hi i'm joran dan and i'm on set on my
first ever gq shoot
my ideal first day it doesn't really
matter as long as the company's great
people say oh i wanna do something fun
and go you know scuba diving or
something crazy like that but that's not
really getting to know somebody
if anybody's on their phone during a day
that's when you know oops the date's
going kind of bad
if i'm not looking at my phone to check
the time then that's when i know it's
working
if i see a guy that i like then i'll
probably you know put a bit more effort
in make sure he notices me i would
seduce him with dancing because i think
i'm kind of good at dancing then he'll
just come up to me hopefully
what are some signs to let a guy know
that i'm interested i think i played my
hair a lot or um i'm not very touchy
feely but i'll probably be like
a bit touchy
the best pickup line i've ever heard i
was actually in new york and i would
pass a guy and he was like damn i'll
climb dead ass
i just thought it was so funny
you